one
and we
are live
on youtube welcome it is your fearful
host
in this residual time of pandemic
podcasting joined
by two phenomenal intellects two
phenomenal friends two phenomenal
thinkers
that uh inspire me and there's over
we're approaching a thousand people
right off the bat
and it's no surprise they're here to see
me no no they're here to see dr eric
weinstein professor avi loeb how are you
guys today
great thank you
we're well thanks i last saw you both
together in miami at a bitcoin
conference where avi you made a stunning
announcement you said go all in on
dogecoin i cannot believe i followed
that advice avi it cost me my pension
such as it is
no i will never give advice that i
personally do not follow
[Laughter]
very good so uh guys we are here to talk
about a variety of topics but i think
none as important as um as this recent
announcement that we recently heard
about from
none other than nasa about uh
about this
phenomenal this decision to actually
study
the uap phenomenon and and what that
might entail
for both
scientists who are not usually
interested in such things but um but uh
kind of orthodox sort of speak
smaller lowercase o
um and so first i want to get uh i want
to get interpretation maybe we'll start
with avi
on this reaction you you have a
wonderful link i put a link to your
medium post about that's called
imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery and um i i just like that very
much so i want i want to get your take
on it what is going on nasa um why do
you think that they've suddenly kind of
maybe i don't want to say change their
tune but but perhaps they have uh what
do you guys um well what do you think
avi first of all right off the bat what
was your reaction well it's relatively
simple to understand what happened that
bill nelson was very intrigued by
unidentified aerial phenomena because as
a senator he saw some classified data
that is not available to the public and
now that he became the head of nasa he
said that
when the director of national
intelligence avery haynes released a
report to congress back a year ago he
said that scientists should get engaged
because he believes it's a serious
matter and
of course he's the head of nasa but
someone has to translate that statement
into action
and
the following morning i contacted the
person responsible for science under him
thomas zurbuchen and
he immediately called me and i told him
look i'm here to
make your boss happy and i'll be glad to
assist you on that and he asked me to
send the white paper which i did but
i've never heard back from him and now
we hear the echo of that
exchange that we had and
a year later nasa in its very sluggish
and political manner uh does something
now what is this something there will be
a committee that will review the
existing data sets
and will recommend to nasa whether to
fund the research programs that will
analyze the existing datasets that are
open to the public and perhaps collect
new data sets and that recommendation
will come in a year or so from now
because the committee will need the nine
months of pregnancy before delivering a
baby and they will start their work only
in about a few months from now so all
together a year from now there will be a
report and then in the best case
scenario nasa would say okay that sounds
intriguing we'll allocate a few million
dollars to this uh
research
agenda and and then the congress will
have to appropriate that fund
those funds and approve them and um and
then the funding will actually be
provided two years from now okay so i'm
saying two years from now we already
have an ongoing galileo project a
scientific research project in two years
we will have enough data to perhaps
change the charter of this study you
know science cannot wait for government
to move
science if it's funded properly
you know operates much faster than that
because we are curious you know i'm just
like a kid i want to figure out the
answer i will not wait for nasa to get
its act together so we establish the
galileo project we'll find out what's
out there the sky is not classified
we'll figure it out
now you had uh kind of recently
celebrated the uh are almost celebrated
the the anniversary of the last time we
spoke on
this podcast but that was in preparation
for this uh announcement of the galileo
project um and i wonder you know if uh
we might think that nasa is somehow
you know really influenced by it
obviously the the title of your post on
medium which i have a link to in the
show notes below here below uh and that
is uh you know refers to imitation so
um we're not talking about the turing
test here so when you made up the the
idea when you had the idea for the uh
for project galileo galileo project was
it really to cast as wide a net as
possible or was it to focus like a laser
using the astronomical tools and
cutting-edge technology that we now have
in the community rather than
having such a wide net that that who
knows what would be captured in your in
your favorite seashore analogy
well there are two approaches that one
can imagine one is waiting for the
government to declassify that data that
bill nelson saw that seems to be very
intriguing because not only he spoke
about it but former
uh cia directors and former
directors of national intelligence spoke
about it as a serious matter and but
that is just like waiting for godot you
know like in the in samuel beckett's
play we can wait forever
a much better approach i mean is to
recognize that the government is not
releasing the data because it was
obtained by a classified sensors it's
not so much that the data is the data
would have been classified if it be if
it indicated activity from china or
russia the data is classified
since the government cannot figure out
what it means and then the sensors used
to derive it are classified and that's
why the data is not publicly shared so i
say forget about it let's just collect
new data science is about
reproducibility of results if we and a
few multi-billionaires showed up at the
porch of my home gave me a couple of
million dollars you know i decided to
allocate it for this project the galileo
project and that's what we are using and
building new telescope systems you have
to understand astronomers look at the
sky but they are focused on very distant
sources of light if a bird flies above
their telescope they ignore it and we
want to focus on that bird and say it's
a bird and if we see a drone it's a
drone but if it's something else not
natural or human-made we will say it's
not natural or human-made and we want
high resolution high quality data so we
use the state-of-the-art eq equipment
it's not a camera on a jittery cockpit
of a fighter jet and it's not eyewitness
testimonies you can't write a scientific
paper based on what people tell you you
know we are not
at ancient times now we have to do so
the galileo project is basically
an attempt to collect new data new
evidence using the scientific method
without prejudice being agnostic about
what we might find in our fishing net we
cast a fishing net it's a fishing
expedition we don't know what we will
find it's probably a mixed bag it will
be a collection of natural objects a
collection of
human-made objects but even if one
object happens to come from an
extraterrestrial technological origin
that would be the most significant
discovery of humanity and
you know that's very different from the
objective of the government which war is
about national security and the safety
of military personnel so they have to
attend to any report irrespective of how
good the data is we don't need to
care about the
fuzzy data
you know or eyewitness testimonies we we
just want one object that has
exceptional data where you can read off
the label made on exoplanet y yeah and
if you look eric at this uh con first of
all i want to give a shout out to eric's
mugs because uh last time he had on the
standard model uh mexican hat and so
forth we drank tequila on cinco de mayo
today's got a donut and that's
appropriate because this is father's day
weekend happy father's day you guys are
father figures not only to uh to your
children your wonderful children but
also to many people around the world
ideologically at least
but i sent out some dad jokes you know
in preparation for this and uh one of
them was what did the donut say to his
lover he said thanks for making me whole
uh eric what is your interest in all of
this is it the dream of not the galilean
those but the einsteins if not the
weinsteins to traverse space and time
what is your interest you've been one of
the most foremost
um scientists that's been looking into
this who also plays a very important
role in public discourse so why do you
care about this for those that might not
be
aware of it
i don't like being lied to
and
i don't like being lied to in particular
about items of national security and i
especially don't like it
when it's done poorly
so one of my chief complaints is is that
if you really have a national security
threat you don't call up
your regular physics corps
for an issue of physical interest
um it's sort of like everything about
this topic is wrong and i don't really
like the topic because
it's one of two super interesting things
to me at this point it's either some
[Music]
multi-decade nonsense campaign which
would explain
why we don't have any really good
video photograph or artifacts that
conclusively end this topic
or it's a
many-year cover-up of
uh an understanding that we've been
dealing with something
almost beyond comprehension which would
explain all the indirect evidence for
this
and it's also the case that
if this is a
real phenomenon
um
of
uh
craft not manufactured on this earth
it's not an issue of technology and i
think we've become
incredibly confused about life that
somehow we're so focused on markets we
only think about technology we don't
think about the change in the science
that would have to explain the new
technology
so the way i look at this um
this is an issue of public trust uh i'm
going to slightly disagree with my
colleague uh professor loeb not with his
conclusion that we have to not wait for
the government but we have to pressure
the government in part by doing this
ourselves because if science is going to
be a public good that we cannot
commercialize because it falls outside
of the intellectual property rules of
our country
we expect a very high level of support
and a very high level of dialogue
and the intrusion of
um
sort of bad tempered
ill-bred children in the
compact between government and science
has been most unwelcome
so it's really important to recognize
that whatever this is
it's important for ris
restoring government credibility if
there's been a giant lie that's been
told for many years we need to
understand it scientifically and undo it
if it's a question of
um there's a real security threat we
need our best people on this so i'm just
sort of having the sense that the world
has gone crazy outside of a small number
of people
and i wasn't crazy but i was stupid i
really just didn't think anything of
this topic until two years ago so i'm
very very late to this party
and in part one of the things that's
really important to me
is
that we not let the people who recognize
that this was a real scientific issue
early
take it on the chin for being early and
then immediately turn to the sort of
blue chip
you know institutional class
to prettify this
and it's very important to me that we
go through a process of restoring
scientific credibility to people who've
made eye contact with this not not
necessarily said it's aliens or it's you
know ufos from uh
from alpha centauri or whatever but
people have said there is something here
it is mysterious and i've now gone deep
enough into this world to understand
that
you're in trouble no matter what
conclusion you come to either you have
to account for why there's no direct
evidence that's worth anything or you
have to account for why there's so much
indirect evidence that would be
seemingly almost impossible to assemble
if there was no there there and neither
of those conclusions is a comfortable
one for me
and the last thing i want to say is is
that you also get into this thing with
the government which i don't understand
where people reach out they tell you
that you're going to be flown out to see
some site to see some evidence you're
prepared to sign an nda you're prepared
to sort of play ball as a good citizen
and as part of the scientific
core of the united states and
and then everything always gets holed
off and held up and we're gonna have to
where there's a committee meeting and
there's some people who need to be
placated and this is an in
i can't tell you how many times this has
now happened with four or five different
channels that don't even seem to be
aware of each other so there's something
very weird about hurry up and wait going
on
with this particular topic in a way that
i've never seen before and i am tired of
being run around if if i'm
put under some agreement i can keep my
mouth shut but i'm gonna be speculating
about what this is up until somebody
tells me what the hell we we actually
know about this very strange phenomena
okay i'm i'm a very naive relative to
eric um
you know i was born on a farm i'm still
a farm boy
so my my naivety shows up in the
following
i i do think that the government is
incapable of hiding something it knows
okay sorry i have you said the
government is in cape you believe that
the government is not capable of of
covering up
at this level yeah
yeah my i just want to collaborate
yeah my guess is the government is
incompetent first of all it's split into
many different sections that deal with
national security and they don't tell
each other what they're doing because of
national security concerns they don't
want too many people to know what each
person does in government okay so that
already introduces a lot of viscosity to
transfer of information okay but on top
of that
on this topic there is a stigma and
people prefer not to talk about it so
that they maintain
an image of being the adult in the room
okay and um so that you combine these
two together and it's possible the
government came across evidence that
once they clarify that it's not china or
russia they say okay we don't want to
sound crazy uh let's just forget about
it since it's not russia or china and
they just leave it aside uh i don't
think it's a matter of um
you know anything beyond it's just that
the government is not a scientific
organization now so it's not malice it's
it's incompetence yeah yeah and for me
and and it's all related to the fact
that
sensors that are used for national
security like for example missile
warning system that need to know about
ballistic missile heading towards the us
you know if they see something that
looks not like a ballistic missile they
don't
you know it's not abolishing they don't
care about if it came from another
planet as long as it's not threatening
the life of people in the us and uh so
my point is that um
government is not a scientific
organization it's motivated by national
security uh considerations and things
that fall outside of that are often
dismissed especially if there is a
stigma on them so now the question is uh
we we hear those reports we hear the
echoes it's sort of like being outside
the room where the adults are speaking
with each other you hear some noises and
it looks like the adults are really
discussing it very seriously so you say
okay there is something there that they
are discussing why are they spending so
much time discussing it you know i'm
just like a kid i hear that that's
discussing something i want to figure
out what it is and the adults don't tell
me what it is
and so i just say okay well the the sky
is not classified let's just figure it
out ourselves you know why why do we
need to wait and listen and i don't have
an issue with government they can do
whatever they want but as a scientist
you know for millions of dollars i can
build equipment that will give me the
answer so it's ridiculous for me to ask
the adults to give me the answer when i
can figure it out myself
yeah and uh i mean obviously this drew a
lot of kind of controversial remarks and
not the you know the requisite amount of
snarkiness uh even from you know
colleagues and folks but but especially
those looking at the budget for this new
nasa program i put the link to a piece
in axios written by a woman miriam
cramer who i don't know but i know her
bio says it's not aliens it's never
aliens uh she i don't know if she
reached out to you avi or eric but yeah
i spoke with her a lot in the past but
yeah go ahead this this is talking about
the riskiness of this nasa program both
reputationally
um you know for the for the normally
stayed and and very impressive
organization government organization
that is nasa but also to the reputation
of astronomers uh katie mack who's a uh
prolific uh denizen of astronomy and and
all things related to public outreach uh
she said something to the effect of uh
you know
we shouldn't connect ufos to
astrobiology or any other thing other
than a sort of aliens of the gaps
argument where people assume that if
they don't have an explanation it might
be aliens how do you react to such a
statement well i should say i'm most
surprised by people that work on seti
because many of them objected to any
scientific study of this and also
resisted allowing in conferences
lectures on this subject it was banned
and now i say okay the government really
wants to know the answer how can the
scientific community shy away from it
it's very often said that we shouldn't
waste taxpayers money well guess what
the government and the public that pays
the taxes are very curious about this so
how can scientists say
no this is too speculative we don't want
to deal with it obviously this should be
in the mainstream of science and
what what you see very often are people
that blog and or or have presence on
social media like the ones you mentioned
and they are just
figuring out where the wind blows they
want to be popular they want to get as
many likes as possible i will not
mention names but they basically say
what they think people would like to
hear okay and i bet you that once the
wind will change direction they will
change direction and to me that's not
the way scientists should work it's not
a
popularity contest we need to figure out
the truth and we need to investigate the
subjects that are of interest to
government and the public
and irrespective of where the wind is
blowing at this moment in time because
the wind will change direction in the
future i've seen it many times in the
context of the planets that were
ridiculed when i started astrophysics uh
gravitational wave astrophysics was
ridiculed you know it's very often that
the wind is blowing in the wrong
direction because it's blowing in the
direction of
so-called experts people that worked on
things for a long while and want to
maintain the landscape of research the
same as they
are familiar with and that's
counteracting innovation in science so
yeah we should ignore that yeah when you
look eric at the you know the transition
since you and i first started talking
about this over two years ago at the
beginning of my pandemic excursions into
podcasting
would you have expected that nasa would
provide a six-figure budget it's rumored
that the budget for the nasa program is
a hundred thousand or so which is only
one
you know 11th of the galileo project
budget i should say that eric you are a
member of the external advisory
committee for project galileo i believe
i used to be but i have since stepped
down due to other uh requirements but uh
eric um is that are you still involved
in galileo project as an external uh
kind of no not external he's in the
research oh he's in the research okay
sorry i i didn't i i didn't recall i was
confused completing myself with eric
roger and i'm interested in yeah i mean
look
there are a lot of people who don't
belong in science
and we sold science as science is fun
and science is a good time and it's not
really true science is a calling and
it's grueling and it's dangerous and all
these things
we need the people who are trying to
spread shame and fear to go back under
their comforters and and
and duvets and hide there until this
gets sorted out nobody knows what this
is
it may be a propaganda campaign on
behalf of the government whatever it is
it's a something and the idea that
putting investigating it puts you at
risk reputation i'm just going to pass
over this in silence it's embarrassing
that we have such people in science
there's not much we can do
um this isn't a question of uh you know
studying astrology there's a claim that
their data exists
there's a tremendous amount of
first-hand
encounters
that
are had with pretty reputable people and
one of the things i've been just shocked
by
is the number of completely sober
individuals
who once or twice in their life
uh appeared to have had some sort of uap
ufo experience that was
effectively impossible to dismiss as
swamp gas or a mylar balloon
and
whatever this is it deserves
investigation even if what we find out
is that you know that there's some
mineral in the water that can induce
hallucinations that look like
cigar-shaped objects whatever it is
doesn't matter
but the most important thing is just to
drive the
shamers and haters out of serious
scientific discourse because
science is based on a certain level of
trust and a certain level of
professional ethics
and
we can't afford such people
trying to steal other people's grants
or trying to ding other people's
reputations just to play the cutthroat
academic version of the hunger games or
the blogging sphere so i think it's
really it's really important just to
recognize what we're talking about is
the scientific equivalent of a mean
girls lunch table in middle school and
it's very important just to drive them
underground and to return fire like
let's not take this as shame
i'm certainly not saying that we're
being visited by aliens i'm saying
something is going on and whether it's a
government disinformation campaign uh or
we've been in contact with little green
men for years i can't tell you what i
can tell you is something is going on
and science investigates the something
and we apologize to no one and
with all due respect and with all the
love from science if you're not down
with that get the hell out of our way
and so
um so um it's very often said to me
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence which is a quote
from carl sagan
but
you know as much as he was a member of
my department many decades ago i
completely disagree with him because
extraordinary evidence requires
extraordinary funding you know we
invested 10 billion dollars to confirm
the higgs boson
through the large hadron collider now
you could have said well it's an
extraordinary claim we don't have
evidence for it the higgs boson doesn't
exist that's not the way science is done
if there is a question that is
worthwhile
either because we have good reasons to
believe that something exists or because
there are reports of anomalous phenomena
in this case from the government from
other sources then we should examine it
and unless you put funds towards it it's
just like sitting at home and saying i
don't have neighbors
well guess what you have to look through
your windows to find your neighbors and
you better use a telescope so it's
completely unprofessional i think it
reflects more
on the quality of those scientists who
make these statements uh
more than on the subject itself and the
stigma
should go the other way
and uh thinking about the culture and
not being able to dissociate it my
comment for you guys is you know your
crosstown rival mit david kaiser he
makes a uh a point in his recent book
quantum legacies
you know that the alien kind of
phenomena first percolated into the
american consciousness around the same
time as the nuclear age the quantum
revolution the electronics digital
revolution um what about this current
epoch i mean i can't escape the fact
that you guys were at this bitcoin
conference where i lost you know all my
money on on dogecoin no no i'm just
kidding but we are going to talk about
an nft project that is uh close to both
uh at least avi and what i'm interested
in with my recent translation of
galileo's dialogue for the first time
and not translation but audiobook um and
an nft associated with it but is there
anything about the zeitgeist the spirit
of the times now that is causing this
where you have senators and and not the
kooky one legitimate senators uh you
know looking at this phenomenon you have
military is there anything in the in the
air so to speak that is commensurate
maybe to a lesser degree than in the
1940s and 50s when this first surfaced
from roswell onward well i think the
data gathering capabilities that we have
are so much better now and so while in
the past you could have said oh it's
probably just
a
malfunction of the detector or whatever
nowadays you cannot ignore it because we
have much better sensors and
uh if you want to ask why now you know i
i
i think it's the accumulation of data
it's the fact that
perhaps you know we are developing these
ai systems you may ask why is there
activity you know
if we are getting close to
creating um
a conscious ai system or
an ai system that is indistinguishable
from the human mind
that would be of interest to
extraterrestrials you know
for us to have a nuclear
reactor you know it's not such a great
accomplishment because they're much
bigger nuclear reactors in the form of
stars out there in nature but there is
nothing like
an artificial intelligence system that
comes along
naturally and that's a milestone that
once we have
a system of that nature could attract
attention
i feel slightly differently about it i
guess
i think that
it may be that when you fuse nuclei
you send a signal that you're pretty
close to the end of the basic rules of
physics and that's controversial because
people like the idea that physics is an
infinite process not like finding all
continental land masses where at some
point you add the last one and you're
done
i'm concerned that
we just don't have a scientific method
extended one of the things that avi and
i talk about is the extension of the
scientific method
um to novel circumstances for example
it's very rare that humans ever study
something more intelligent than
themselves
um
speak for yourself speak for yourself
eric well i i'm married as well so um i
i do study my wife's behavior but that's
not what i was getting at thank you for
bringing that up good good what we have
is a situation in which what if you're
the rat in a psychologist's maze and
you're trying to figure out
when the psychologist provides you with
sugar water or cheese
[Music]
everything reverses it's also the case
that when we capture technology
if we capture it from the wild we're
usually talking about a chimpanzee has
figured out how to fish ants
with a stick
it's not usually the case that we come
across something like a computer or a
spaceship that has capabilities that we
lack i mean an example of this would be
like the antique theory mechanism
which was discovered in a shipwreck dive
where it was a human civilization but
one far more advanced
uh than any we had known about
like a thousand years ago so the
scientific method has to be extended one
of the reasons i'm interested in the
galileo project is the discussion about
how what's what is the responsible
extension of the scientific method it's
also the case for example if you look at
cuttlefish skin
it's probably the most advanced
camouflage system found in nature
what if somebody so in the ufo uap world
that would be called signature
management
and what would the what would it be like
to study something that doesn't want to
be studied is more advanced than you are
is studying you while you are studying
id
uh and knows physical laws that you know
nothing of i just spent um several days
at two physics conferences at ucla that
zv byrne was was organizing
and in the first one um
nima arkani hamed from the institute for
advanced study brought up one of his
favorite points which is the demise of
space-time that space-time is doomed and
it is only going to be seen in the
future as an emergent
mathematical structure a map which is
not the territory
the interesting thing about that though
is
if you take the point of view that
space-time is merely an effective theory
then you have to ask yourself the
question does the theory that renders
space-time and effective theory that
contains space-time does that have new
degrees of freedom
that something else can get access to
and that we're trapped in this much
lower
dimensional
more compressed effective theory while
something else is aware of a of a
more fundamental theory and in that
paradigm
um
there is the scientific method is
relatively mute on most of these topics
so we we tend to believe that we're in
general position we're smarter than what
we're studying we can repeat it many
times at will
and all of these things have to be
adjusted and we've met that a little bit
with respect to things like the big bang
and the surface of last scattering
you know and i think avi made a really
brilliant point although he made it in a
way that i might slightly disagree with
but the point is much better than my
disagreement the point is is that
intelligence
may be much rarer
than fusion which i totally agree with
and i think that that's a really
interesting thing but it may be also
that the reason that we have summoned
something to our shores
is that we've indicated something that
we do not know we may think physics is
going to go on forever and whatever it
is that may be watching us
may know exactly how close we are to
parody with it so rather than it being
tens of millions of years more advanced
than ourselves which is very
much in keeping with the zeitgeist of
today the zeitgeist of today is against
individual achievement it's against the
triumph of human intelligence it's
against the idea of power laws where
certain people
are much more productive than teams of
others etc etc
this thing may know
that we are much farther along and much
more of a threat to it than we know we
are if you think about it
what if you suddenly found that orcas
had developed opposable flippers
and were
just miles ahead of what we thought
you know large dolphins could do in the
sea it would give us a huge shock
[Music]
what i think is is that it is entirely
possible that whatever the success or
the space time is allows for things that
we can't yet think about
and
that it may be that we're a lot farther
towards learning our fundamental truth
than we know and that that may be uh of
interest to something watching us
yeah if i may add to what eric just said
um
you know the one thing that marks the
current time is the development of um
ai artificial intelligence systems that
may be
uh eventually similar to the human mind
and um you just
if you ever push the baby on in a
stroller on the street you would
recognize that
the baby when it passes by other babies
uh finds them much more interesting than
yourself um and then
therefore you know if we are dealing
with ai astronauts
my baby likes the toaster oven better
than me
it's not saying much
but uh my but my point is simple that
you know we are used to darwinian
evolution here on earth where
random processes
select the fitest the the survival of
the fittest um and then
in fact the extension of that once we
started developing technologies
technological selection not natural
selection but technological selection in
interstellar space it's those gadgets
that are autonomous
don't need guidance from their senders
then their senders may be dead by now
these are ai astronauts
and they may be also our destiny our
future if we send out those monuments of
sentient
ai systems to space
there might i can guarantee that to you
that they are much better than the
monuments you find
uh in
for example harvard square uh harvard
yard uh which are monuments of past
presidents and deans that try to
preserve their physical image
these are static
sculptures and when kids pass by them
they usually yawn and my point is that
sending ai astronauts is our future and
it may have been the future of
other civilizations because you know
most of the sun-like stars from billions
of years before the sun so they were
just ahead of us
and one thing i wanted to ask you i've
been working on it in my mind uh since
you and i had a chance to talk
over a year ago when you launched the uh
galileo project and gave me that scoop
uh that i appreciate so much and that
was uh with reference to the fact that
we don't seem to see aliens in our solar
system and the reason i think that's
significant in the you know context of
what fred hoyle and others called
panspermia uh seems to be at least at
some level capable
of establishing you know an upper limit
on evolutionary facility or in some way
in other words we've had life on earth
for how long have you four billion year
three billion years something like that
yeah hundreds of millions of years it
started hundreds of millions of years
after the earth cooled so yeah it was
really quick billions
and and it's efficient once it gets
started and and replication occurs and
information storage obeys
now we haven't searched everywhere and
and your friend carl sagan that we spoke
about i have a finger puppet of him here
you know he said absence of evidence is
an evidence of absence he said all sorts
of things like fine men i love when
people quote feynman you know he'll say
something like um uh you know if you
can't explain it to your grandmother you
don't understand it and then he'll say
if i could explain it to you a newspaper
reporter it isn't worth a nobel prize so
i don't want to make too much of these
great you know people in the pantheon of
science um in history but the fact that
we don't see any life on any elsewhere
else in the in the unit in the solar
system even can that be used to set some
kind of a limit on the ability for us to
you know place bayesian priors on the
likelihood of finding life outside the
solar system let alone technological
life or am i just way off here
no i mean it's life can be very subtle
for example it can be under the ice of
enceladus or europa
uh and we haven't drilled the ice yet to
find out if there is any fish in the
ocean under it uh
there were some
astronomers suggesting last year that
perhaps uh in the there is life in the
clouds of venus you know so these are
very exotic environments and the life
would be quite different than we find
here on earth but um
i i think we are really at the infancy
of searching and and it may be different
from earth for sure because the physical
conditions there are different so it's
sort of like going on a date without
knowing what what your date would look
like
and so you're looking around the room
and it doesn't look like it's a you
there is a human like yourself out there
but that doesn't mean that your date is
not next to you in some different form
you know
yeah um so uh eric when we think about
the kind of motivation perhaps of uh
journalists or other non-government
organizations um
how do you actually assess this you've
been very vocal about the need as you
just articulated to not humiliate people
it's not part of science but journalists
aren't scientists right they're the
first to admit that hopefully um what
standards of journalism do you think
there need to be
if any to report on such things without
you know encouraging ridicule and the
prosthetic forehead problem of you know
uh of uh that is worthy of ridicule at
some level what do you think can be done
about this in the public social media
sphere etc
i i don't know where good journalism is
still being done i mean i sometimes look
at quanta and think
highly of what's
written there
but in general i've sort of just become
aghast at what twitter has done to
journalists where we we now have
basically activists uh recruited as
journalists because it can sell legacy
media
um obviously the right thing is uh is
professional standards which are tacit
understandings of what you cannot do
and
i i'm concerned that there's something
about our phones that
um
tens everything
makes everything tend in the direction
of interpersonal drama
and
uh in order to get funding in order to
get coverage this has to become
uh about you know so-and-so's reputation
on the rocks tune in next week when
we'll hear and and this is nonsense it's
completely antithetical to what science
is when i look at
the g minus two uh muon anomaly in the
discussion i was just listening to for
several days you have these collegial
groups
that are you know sort of at each
other's throats but everything is
extraordinarily professional and careful
and
the whatever rivalries there are are not
at this lunch table level so i think
that the basic issue is
we've just got to get rid of
people who
the emphasis on people who go after
other people because they can't do their
job either as scientists or as
journalists covering science and we need
to replace them with better paid people
in trusted positions
who weigh things
and it's also i just wanted to say that
there's one other community that i'm
going to call out i don't want to
get into specifics but the debunking
community is really disappointing
because what it's doing is it's crowding
out critique
and critique really matters
and snark and debunking and dragging and
and uh
all of this dunking on stuff is some
sort of abomination
that
we need to get rid of what i'm curious
about right now
is
what is our best
data
who holds it who may see it
i
applaud
avi's attempt to say we should get our
own data
but it's also completely ridiculous that
a small number of government physicists
determined by their security clearances
rather than by their facility with
equations seems to be in charge of this
as their portfolio
and what i would say is that it's really
important for
really prominent names in the in the
theory community
to start calling for an unsealing of
this stuff
and i have to say that i'm very
suspicious
of a government trying to keep a secret
and a legion of um
journalists who seem to be helping them
by stigmatizing anyone who asks for the
secret so i just want to take a couple
of other things that are really
interesting
peter dazek
was clearly doing something in wuhan
with this virus we haven't held hearings
we haven't figured it out jeffrey
epstein was doing something trafficking
children under everybody's noses
no journalist has called for
even the bare minimum examination of
documents related to what is probably a
fictional hedge fund and whether or not
he was tied to the intelligence
community the fire bombing of the
federal courthouse in portland
was not covered in real time
in a meaningful way
given the level of violence being done
to a federal building
in all of these circumstances whether
it's hunter biden's laptop
we've seen something really interesting
which is the
the appearance of anti-interesting
stories stories that are professional
legacy media
refuses to cover no matter how much
interest is expressed by the population
and which is later found
that whatever the attempt to stigmatize
the story
there was far more there in all of these
cases than anyone had imagined so i
think we now have to look at the ufo uap
story
in light of all of these other stories i
am absolutely positive that people were
trying to firebomb the federal
courthouse in portland and that for some
reason
msnbc was not keen to cover it just the
way they weren't keen to cover andrew
yang's presidential run something is
happening in our journalistic layer
which is causing stories to be
anti-interesting and there's nothing
more anti-interesting than jeffrey
epstein in ufo uap when i think about
that okay go ahead
um because
moving away from politics
into science and academia okay and the
same approach that eric is worried about
in the context of politics and and the
media you can find among mainstream
scientists so on the one hand
uh ridiculing the study of uap even
though there is data and evidence and
science is all about collecting more
evidence if some evidence looks
intriguing that's all that science is
about evidence
whereas
while ridiculing that
maintaining a mainstream that is focused
on extra dimensions for which we have no
evidence
focused on
some notions
of space and time that were never
validated by any experiment that never
made a prediction
that was confirmed
and yet awards and honors are given to
mainstream scientists just for proposing
them and then to other mainstream
scientists just for
invalidating them experimentally and one
example was the large extra dimensions
you know the the person who proposed it
got a prize and the person who did an
experiment later to show that it's there
cannot be a large extra dimension got
the price in so i said we went full
circle here and we proven that an idea
is not correct so why why was it in the
mainstream to start with and what you
find is a lot of the activity in
theoretical astrophysics theoretical
physics is rooted in ideas that were
never tested never validated so i said
that's perfectly fine you know we can
think about possibilities that's
perfectly fine but at the same time when
there is intriguing evidence to dismiss
it and ridicule it that's inappropriate
this is a culture that prefers
to live in a virtual reality basically
ideas that bring you pleasure it's just
like putting goggles on your head and
living in the metaverse where you are
the smartest scientist in the world but
that's not the way science should be
done you should be wrong every now and
then by comparing your ideas to data
and that's you know you should be
bruised sometimes because you propose
something that turns out to be wrong and
the only way to allow that is to follow
data to look for evidence and and the
strange thing is that not
accepting that rule and basically
asking how many angels can sit on the
tip of a dance on the tip of a pin
that's an ex especially in extra
dimensions that's a completely
acceptable in
mathematical intellectual gymnastics
exercise that a lot of communities can
agree on and give each other but when
you ask yourself
how can that replace
this seeking experimental tests that
looks to me very much you know the
science is supposed to teach the public
and government how to do how to deal
with evidence so scientists very often
say oh the government doesn't pay
attention to evidence doesn't pay
attention to data but if you look at the
academic
community it's actually worse
and i ask myself how is that possible
we're supposed to set an example
by which we follow evidence if there are
uap that look intriguing we say okay
that's interesting let's figure it out
you know that's the way scientists
should approach it but instead
no the data is uninteresting it's not
real forget about it let's just work on
extra dimensions like i say that's
completely opposite to what scientists
should do well i don't know if the i
mean i push back with respect as you
know uh and and i do feel like it's a
little bit of a strawman to suggest that
somebody could pivot from extra
dimensions to doing the type of
astronomy that even you don't do avi i
mean you're not actually sitting in a
telescope every night i mean you're a
theoretical astrophysicist of the
highest order and you've written on this
and you know the astronomical technology
depression is not what i do the question
is what do i value okay and i value
evidence and when there is intriguing
evidence i will not ridicule the
evidence just
on some hypothetical idea so the real
issue is that some people within our
community prefer to work on theoretical
ideas just because they flatter their
ego and they prefer to shy away from
data i'm not talking about one year two
years i'm talking about four decades
we're talking about the career
of many scientists
yeah okay
the funny problem that we have here is
that we poke holes
for certain conspiracies certain
outlandish ideas and not others
right so there are various outlandish
ideas that you're allowed to discuss in
public including conspiracies like that
russia is running the united states
through donald trump that was an
allowable conspiracy that he was a foot
soldier of putin
but then there are conspiracies that
you're not allowed to now the same thing
is true for scientific theories there
are outlandish scientific theories that
have somehow
diplomatic immunity from the regular
scientific process and others that do
not
and so we have hyper scrutiny for some
and extremely lacks relaxation of the
rules for others and this is in part a
mystery
that there is no real scientific method
that's generating this concept of the
mainstream if leading people want to
work on something outlandish that become
that outlandish thing becomes the
mainstream
and if certain people want to take a
look at evidence and go through
absolutely normal scientific channels to
look at something that people don't want
discussed
that becomes aberrant fringe weird
cranky behavior now the fact is that
that doesn't really have a lot to do
with any objective standard it has to do
with the fact that there is an overton
window in science just the way there is
in political discourse
and you know if you wanted to study uh
what causes ulcers and you didn't
believe it was stress
um you had to experiment on yourself at
some point because that was so much a
part of the orthodoxy in all of these
situations where you've seen something
fall something outlandish
we saw this with the asymmetry of the
weak force
the evidence was accumulating but it was
just this thing where nobody wanted to
say
the weak force has no clothes you know
it was an emperor that we dare not
question and so in a certain sense it's
not really about extra dimensions or ufo
uap the question is
are we as scientists allowed to say hey
why is string theory
allowed to go on this way or large extra
dimensions or loop quantum gravity but
not uap ufo even to gather data to
dismiss it by saying we had sensors up
and we found nothing
so i think oh sorry go ahead just to
close it out i think that the real issue
is it's a little disturbing to many of
us
that there are allowable relaxations of
the scientific uh method and there are
extremely harsh harsh applications of
scientific standards that are wielded
selectively like a cop in a town you
know penalizing people who look a
certain way and enforcing the speed
limit extremely aggressively and letting
other people speed through at 100 miles
an hour
and doffing their cap to them
encouraging them on their way that's a
real problem that we haven't addressed
and nobody really wants to take up
so i want to ask avi um you know as a
professional professional courtesy what
what do you mean by data i mean i have
here i'm in my office that used to be
belong to jeff and margaret burbidge
towering titans of astronomy and physics
of the past hundred years here's a plate
she took on uh at lick observatory it's
a it's a it's a galaxy she eventually
did a rotation curve here's the spectrum
of it uh on one hand you know these are
smudges on on pieces of glass that are
very fragile the other hand they're
pretty pictures and on the other hand
they're data and i want to ask you when
i hear colleagues say we need data and
the data need to be public and god damn
it the hubble space telescope was built
by nasa and i own it what is data i mean
the hubble deep field is a pretty
picture there's very little science
correct me if i'm wrong obvi i'll defer
to you uh you know if i'm wrong but you
know it's a pretty picture there is data
there is evidence that can be extracted
to to look at distributions and and and
number counts and colored magnitude
diagrams you can do all sorts of things
with it but if you don't have the
calibration the flat field the the dark
current if you don't have all the stuff
that goes into it so i want to ask you
what data are you are we really talking
about i mean is it cell phone camera
videos is it like eyewitness reports
what what is it exactly avi uh and then
i'd like to hear eric's uh taking this
so what i mean by data is
uh
the
accumulation of quantitative signals
that are collected and documented by
instruments that you have full control
over and whose background you understand
okay so it cannot be a camera in a
jittery cockpit of a fighter jet it
cannot be the pilot because people are
not instruments they have hallucinations
they have wishful thinking so you cannot
write a scientific paper saying this
person told me that i'm sorry i mean
even if the person is sincere that
cannot be used in a scientific
peer-reviewed journal okay so what i
mean by data is first of all you build
instruments that you fully understand in
terms of what is the background noise in
the instrument so that you can detect a
signal and then you let the instrument
do its job and
report back the numbers that it measured
and then you interpret those and that's
what the galileo project is trying to do
we are we were asked why aren't we uh
crowdsourcing or crowd you know
providing people
an app that they will put on their
iphone so that they will give us data
this is low quality data that we have no
control over we would rather build
instruments that we fully understand
under conditions that are fully under
our control
and then
interpret the data that they collect
because then we can say look this
instrument saw an object let's say in
the infrared another instrument detected
the same object in the optical the
object was moving along the same
trajectory in both instruments it cannot
be malfunctioned of the instrument and
we know the acceleration cannot be
produced by human-made vehicles and it
cannot definitely be representative of a
bird because we know the distance to
this object so these are the kinds of
measurements that will tell us it's
something else or if we have a high
resolution image where we can see the
bolts and the screws on the surface of
the object so it cannot be natural a
rock doesn't have bolts and screws on it
or if we go and do an expedition to
papua new guinea where we collect the
fragments from the first interstellar
meteor that landed there in 2014 and
then we find that the composition of
those fragments is
some alloy that is completely artificial
that you don't find in nature
then it's something else so what i'm
talking about are uh
you know collection of quantitative
measurements that indicate that it's
something quite unusual now we did have
partial evidence of that type on omuamua
the first interstellar object reported
uh we have some partial information
about this meteor that i mentioned from
2014 four years before umuah that my
student amir siraj and i discovered and
the government confirmed a couple of
months ago
and we know that this meteor was denser
or tougher than iron because it burned
only 20 kilometers above ocean level
where the stress is above well above uh
the yield stress of
iron so so we know that it was unusual
but we don't know for sure what its
origin was and we know that it came from
outside the solar system so right now we
have intriguing evidence the same as for
uap we we don't have a conclusive
argument at the moment but that's why we
should be motivated to find more data
and it always reminds me of my colleague
that after a lecture at harvard about
omua mua this colleague of mine focused
on studying rocks for decades so when he
left the auditorium he said to me
omoamoa is so weird i wish it never
existed and that is completely the
opposite to what a scientist a true
scientist should say
obviously an expert would like to
interpret everything based on his or her
past knowledge but
if you are a real scientist you should
say this object is so intriguing i would
like to get more data on it it's really
exciting
lenin reportedly said you might not be
interested in war
but war is interested in you
you might not be interested in aliens uh
but uh but eric what extent should you
know you and i have talked extensively
about the general demarcation paparian
ideas but at what level would you say to
avi give it up man omo
it's like in other words what would it
take for for you and me or maybe to
convince avi and then avi want to ask
what would you be convinced by that
omumua is not as your book of the same
name phenomenal book best seller smash
hit extraterrestrial what would convince
you avi but first i want to ask eric is
that a good question even to ask
you know more or less my experience with
avi is that when avi gets something
wrong he's eager to say that he's got it
wrong
and
that shouldn't be a remarkable
characteristic of a scientist i'm sorry
to say but
you know just the willingness to
entertain being wrong um
it's contagious and it's immediately
recognizable so my feeling is i don't
really need to tell it's not like avi is
under some kind of a watch and we have
to say like maybe he's gone around the
bend on a muah
i think what he's doing is is that he's
trying to show
conviction and might avi be wrong
yes it does not shock avi that i think
he might be wrong and nor does it
threaten our relationship i think that
this just
we've got to take the mtv uh
out of science in order to recognize
that being wrong and making bold
conjectures is normal and if you don't
if everything you've ever said is true
and is right and works you're probably
not really pushing the cutting edge
um i think
that in terms of data uh
one of the great problems that we have
here is that every time
[Music]
you try to take the perspective of
somebody on the outside saying well
maybe it's bs maybe there's something
there i don't know and you're talking to
these people who are ex-government or
aerospace contractors or in government
there's this very awkward moment where
they get so frustrated with this they
say
i just wish i could show you what we
have because
it would end this conversation instantly
so the claim is made repeatedly by
different people
that what is held in terms of
like i don't know satellites that have
tracked objects coming in from
you know outside
of earth orbit at incredible speeds and
non-ballistic trajectories you know the
claim is we have all sorts of crazy data
that may not be very visual in the sense
of
oh look a floating tic tac
but are scientifically much more
interesting because let's say you have
you know five different sensors on the
same object and you're absolutely
convinced
that it would be incredible to spoof all
of them
or it would have to be a conspiracy or
something so the claim that is made
repeatedly by people in positions
[Music]
with security clearances and the like
is that the data is completely clear
that we're dealing with a real
uh phenomena
and
that's really tough on me because i
haven't seen anything that looks
remotely
like that in other words
i'm so
bored of these three tantalizing videos
that got released and all of the cool
stuff that shot on people's
iphones you know the other week i saw
a supposed uap video shot out of a a
plane in which a giant whale broke
through the clouds
and splashed back into the clouds as if
they were the you know the surface of
the ocean and i thought well that's much
higher quality than most of the ufo
videos i've ever seen
um so in a weird sense
the video stuff as data you know to
obvious point is completely clear that
it's not very helpful
what is claimed is is that there is
extremely high quality data that
completely settles the question of
whether we're looking at something real
or not
i've never seen this data i've heard it
discussed many times people have
threatened to show it to me people have
threatened to fly me to a location
there's something that has happened
every single time so i now expect that
i'm going to get some phone calls from
people who claim to have this data who
claim that this is going to happen and
then it doesn't happen and it's not just
me that this has happened to it's
repeatedly with various people so i
think that in part
whatever is going on here um it's a dime
that was flipped and has landed on its
side for like 75 years
and since a dime is not going to stay in
an unstable equilibrium on its side you
have to ask the question is that in fact
a new piece of data what does one make
of the fact that a dime could land on
its side for you know 70 years without
clear data getting into the public's
hands so that anybody with a you know a
competency can look at it and say this
is not consistent with anything known to
man
and avia uh well let me just first re
reset the stage here um talking with my
friends dr eric weinstein
proprietor of the portal podcast
and um general racontour impresario uh
advisor friend and uh mentor to many uh
graduate of harvard which we'll get into
in just a bit and uh the frank baird
professor uh at harvard former
longest-serving chair from that wrong of
harvard's uh uh renowned astronomy
department author of number one
best-selling book extraterrestrial
professor avi loeb of harvard and i am
your humble podcast host brian keating
proprietor of the into the impossible
podcast where i make videos in short
form and long form interviews like this
but also short form explainers i've yet
to do one about you know how we would
actually collect data from this but avi
i wanted to ask you first of all do you
want to respond to the to the outrageous
accusation that i made i mean could you
be proven wrong could um is there
anything conceivable that i could how
how and how would i do it how would i do
it more importantly
i'm really surprised that you're asking
this because remember this image from
osiris-rex this mission that landed on
the asteroid bennu okay then it will
bring a sample of the material that this
asteroid was made of to earth next year
yeah so it was clear from the image when
it landed
that it's a rock it was obvious okay and
i would never argue that this is not a
rock because it looks like a rock now
what did my colleagues suggest for omua
moa they suggested it's a rock of a type
that we've never seen before because the
rock of the type that we had seen before
cannot explain all the anomalies okay so
they suggested maybe it's a hydrogen
iceberg a chunk of frozen hydrogen this
is
and then they suggested maybe homo is a
frozen hydrogen and then we don't see
the cometary tail because hydrogen is
transparent and
and i did a calculation that was
published where we showed that
actually it would get evaporated very
quickly through interstellar space so it
cannot be a hydrogen but let's imagine
it is okay then the suggestion was okay
well it's not a hydrogen iceberg maybe
it's a nitrogen iceberg that was chipped
off a planet like pluto
and the problem is there is not enough
solid nitrogen but let's leave that
aside there is not enough solid nitrogen
to explain the population of this
magnitude but let's just say okay maybe
it's a nitrogen iceberg again something
we've never seen before and the third
possibility was a dust bunny a a cloud
of dust particles a hundred times less
dense than air so that it gets pushed by
reflecting sunlight without any cometary
tail and i say these are the
the leading possibilities that the
mainstream of astronomers suggested and
you asked me to say you know what would
convince me that it's very simple you
send something like osiris-rex if it
flies through the object then it's a
dust bunny because a cloud of dust
particles a hundred times less dense in
air is so fluffy you can pass through it
now if it's a hydrogen
iceberg or nitrogen iceberg when you
land on it it's obvious i can i i'm
willing
uh
to bet that it's neither of these three
okay now you ask me what could it be i
say i don't know but maybe it is
artificial in origin that's all i'm
saying maybe it's a leaflet leaflet from
another civilization that was thin and
straight and there is a message on it i
don't know what it is we can only
imagine but maybe but then you know
again
my point is we can find out easily by
going there okay that's my point so all
right
my objective is to find out the answer
and i don't care if i'm wrong or not
what i care about is people saying it's
a rock of a type that we've never seen
before case clause forget about it
discussion clause and ridiculing the
other option when it's not ruled out
brian let me ask you a question
why drag this discussion
to have us constantly talk about this
group of people that we shouldn't really
be letting
guide the discussion in other words
you're sort of saying ah just to give
you the chance to respond my feeling is
when did these people get the
credibility
to tell not these people hold on hold on
hold on it's not these people it's me so
when avi was on the podcast to discuss
um in january 2021 i said to him avi you
know you know some billionaires and i
didn't know about galileo project at
that point now i know he knows more
billionaires
and so i'm going to be extra nice in my
uh in my gift basket to you this this
coming fall but i said avi put your
money where your mouth is have your
friend who sponsored the breakthrough
pros have him uh yuri uh milner have him
instead of directing cell phone cameras
to proxima centauri b send those sensors
to omumua or something equivalent to it
and you said to me
hold on hold on eric hold on hold on
obvio said to me no it's okay because
vera rubin observatory which i agree
will have the capability we should see
hundreds of these things but i said avi
there are things that in sciences we
know that are three sigma four sigma so
they should only occur by fluke one out
of every five million times and we know
they happen much more often than what if
a moomoo is kind of the opposite of that
what if it's a one the one chunk of
interstellar message in a bottle we can
oh miss it if you don't apply funding
and rockets and so forth to it so i want
to give you a chance to respond but the
amazing thing is that we do have funding
so these multi-billionaires came to the
porch of my home funded the galileo
project
just a week ago i said we need funding
for the expedition to papua new guinea i
just said that we need the funding
within a week i got half a million
dollars now i tell you as department
chair
of the astronomy department at harvard
you know we've been trying for a decade
to raise similar funds to the giant
magellan telescope right okay and
here i didn't do any fundraising people
came to me and said that's inspiring we
like the vision we enjoyed your book so
i'm telling you the public cares about
it the government cares about it wealthy
individuals care about it i did not
entice them they came to me and said
here is the money no strings attached
how can you explain that many of my
colleagues work extremely hard to break
those funds or get committees in
tennessee for nasa give them even a
small fraction of those funds they just
come to me over the past decade i was
fully funded by the private sector and
that allows me to be free in my thinking
and i think that is the way of the
future because but what happens in
federal funding agencies very often is
that they
follow the advice of committees that are
populated by mainstream scientists those
colleagues that ridicule deviations from
the beaten path and as a result you
don't get people
going in directions that are not
not conservative so i think that the
current funding system is flowed
brian let me just try to get back to
what i said that started this
avi is in a very
enviable position
as one of the most visible and
successful scientists in this area he's
sitting at harvard he's got an enormous
number of publications very high h index
et cetera et cetera chaired professor
and what if somebody came out of the
university of kentucky and said the same
sorts of things that avi was saying and
you said well if you're so sure of that
why don't you send a probe you know and
this gets really tiresome and really
irritating
the problem has to do with
i don't want to base these discussions
any longer
on an anchor
of this
backbiting hating community where we
have to answer these questions well how
would you answer this and how would you
answer that
the polite answer is the adults are
talking and you're not running the
conversation
so we have to get back to an
understanding that avi may be fully
funded and avi may be in a position to
be fully funded and i think that that's
great but pushing everybody to release
an nft or cozy up to a billionaire
is not practical for science in general
and i'm going to stand up for the
portion of us that said we had a
relationship with the federal government
or the federal government more or less
knew when to leave us alone and it knew
how to protect people for their careers
our private universities are not private
they're all federally funded
they may claim to be private but they're
all getting huge amounts of money
through overhead and indirect
recovery etc etc
we have a relationship to defend because
we produce a public good that is
inexhaustible and inexcludable
and quite honestly i'm not giving up on
the government just because we've had an
explosion of
kind of
centrist
popularity contest thinking in science
we need to get back to the point where
somebody with a good idea from the
university of kentucky who knows no
billionaires has a very good chance of
getting funded if it flies straight in
the face of somebody at princeton
and
whether or not
the faculty at stanford or the
university of chicago is upset by this
is irrelevant the key question is where
there are good ideas do we have smart
people with slush funds who can throw
money
that is not directed by consensus or
peer review or popularity contests or
reputational concerns
what i'm asking you from the into the
impossible podcast is
can we allow the journalistic groups
that say is nasa putting its reputation
at stake question mark
can we give them the week the year the
decade off and actually conduct
scientific discussions amongst ourselves
without constantly being referenced to
these people because this is a pretty
serious issue and i'm perfectly happy to
find out that there's not a single shred
of evidence of any extraterrestrial
visitation but that there's been an
enormous campaign to hide our spy planes
and our stealth technology which took on
this form well that's kind of whatever
it is
whatever it is
the plea is
can you stop asking questions of the
form how would you respond to the person
who just wrote an article who said the
following thing and the answer is f off
that's how i'd respond science is being
done and we can't constantly reference
ourselves to some journalist who didn't
know what they were talking about on
deadline who actually can't solve a
partial differential error it's not just
that navi will you know certainly
reciprocate this sentiment it's not just
the journalist it's it's the seti
community it's the it's the other
scientists it's authors of books about
you know from scientific perspective
that have interviewed avi
astrobiologist who should who who would
be left
we've created a world where everyone has
to guard her or his reputation
constantly in order to stay one more
year in the good graces of this
communalist system that figures out who
can breathe and whose oxygen gets shut
off
so the point is is that those colleagues
are worth much less than colleagues of
60 years ago
and the fact is that in the hunger games
that we've created i'm much less
interested what the person down the hall
thinks about this work or that work what
i'm most interested in is
which scientists have the ability to say
i may have screwed up i'm not 100 sure
here are the things that would change my
mind
and i'm least interested
in the scientists who say oh
that's out there that's spicy
that's weird
those people need to be ejected and what
i'm going to say is is that inclusion
has been much trumpeted but exclusion is
just as important who we exclude from
the conversation is critical to the
progress of science and i'm trying to
say that there are people there are
voices sneaking into this q a
that i'm eager to exclude not because i
believe that their dissident voices who
must be heard and that i want to
step on them what i'm instead suggesting
is that trying to murder ideas in their
inco at infancy
is absolutely antithetical to science
and what we need to be doing is making
sure that we i'm here to level the
playing field in part
and we need to step up and say that
certain people myself not included were
early on this
certain people myself included
got some bad information went after
people not understanding what the
current situation was
and as somebody who got this topic
completely wrong
it's important that we talk to people
who switch their minds and who can say i
screwed up rather than people who seem
to always have their finger in
in the air
and always seem to know exactly what the
current prevailing ideas are and and
that's what i'm suggesting i don't think
that our colleagues are as important now
as they used to be because they're all
on life support and it can be turned off
and we all know it and they all know it
well eric you know i have to respond
just because you are you know kind of
painting me as and from the perspective
of you know someone who's attacking
without actually capturing what i'm
doing what i'm doing is a process that
we call annealing that your friend
nicholas tele would call anti-fragility
right the more scientific scrutiny that
avi's claims are my claims in science or
your claims withstand the better it
actually no makes makes
no no no no
no no
it hinges on the word scrutiny and
critique
what i'm trying to say is is that we
have to jealously defend the gatekeeping
of what constitutes critique
and what i'm claiming is absolutely avi
needs to be critiqued but
i go back to paul durock paul durock
made it a very clear point which is you
have to make sure that ideas are not
subject
to
you know the most rigorous um experiment
uh agreement with experiment criteria
too early
and in part
i it's like infant industries we have to
protect new ideas like maybe this is an
artificial entrant not because
uh that's a great idea i have no opinion
avi could be completely wrong about
amumu i've got zero zero dogs in that
fight
what i am saying is is that it takes
incredible courage right now to say
something like that and to pretend that
the okay but to to then
claim that the the critiques
uh are something that you need to
subject this isn't anti-fragility it's
like saying we don't need a bi-lipid
layer for the cell because all the
organelles should uh you know withstand
full contact with the environment
[ __ ] what you need is is a bi-lipid
layer with some very careful gates to
regulate what gets in and what gets out
and i don't want to give the community
that is taking an easy pot shot here or
there the same status as the careful
community who says i think you blew
something in equation seven right let me
let avi yeah go ahead
you studied the galileo right yesterday
yes
do you think he would have been so
wouldn't you agree that he would have
been canceled on social media today
he would have been cancelled many times
and he would have been canceled for his
scientific ideas in part but also his
political ideas right
he got a lot of things wrong as well as
being brilliant right as all scientists
do
but but my point is
we can't let
uh
society control the ideas we have we
should allow evidence to guide us and
some people are wrong and it's a
learning experience so my point is it's
not about it's not a personal context
you know it's not showing that we are
smart nature is smarter than all of us
that's why i think if we ever find
clear evidence for a smarter kid on the
block it would bring us to our senses
because we keep competing with each
other just like kids in the kindergarten
you know playing in the sandbox and then
suppose the kids look away and there is
a car passing by you know it shows them
the world is much bigger yet there is
something much more sophisticated going
out there and why would we fight with
each other about who is slightly more
intelligent who pushed the
problem in extra dimensions that we
don't know exist rather than just look
around and pay attention to the evidence
that looks intriguing you know that is
the natural thing to do and for some
reason it's being abandoned these days
abandoned because people prefer virtual
realities it's sort of like being high
on drugs and preferring a reality that
gives you pleasure on a reality that is
the actual one that we share yeah well
science is a painstaking process you
don't get the instantaneous dopamine
hits of thumbs up and oh sick burn and
this is you know avi got taken down in
front of this crowd and eric said this
to brian and defenestrated him uh but
but the the point is i wouldn't be
having this conversation if i wasn't
deeply interested and and putting my
scientific bona fides you know in in
your service as i did for the past year
with my
miniscule and and very minor
contributions whatever i did but the
point is you know when when i think
about collecting data and the process of
it i i hear it said that you know
everything should be made you know
public we should foia the hell out of
the government um but on the other hand
i also think like people if you can't
get scientists to do it it may mean
that that they're not interested and
they're not truly curious the way
galileo or einstein was but it may be
that they have used whatever scientific
you know acumen they have to triage the
problems that they're going to be
involved in and this one doesn't rise to
the threshold of being interested and
that's not a criticism i'm just saying
that's an explanation
okay i'm a scientist and i'm interested
in it yep
okay so let you know i prefer to go in a
path that was not taken the way robert
frost phrased it in his poem uh for him
it was the thing that
you know uh made made a difference for
in his life for me it's the ability as a
physicist to find low-hanging fruit
because nobody walked that path and
there might be something really obvious
that we will find so my point is i'm a
scientist i'm and why would that be an
issue to someone if the garlow project
is funded by the private sector
following it why would that even raise
an eyebrow that everyone should be happy
about it but eric's not saying that
eric's saying it shouldn't have to be it
should be funded by the public which i
agree with it should be publicly funded
but i also think that eric's saying
maybe something i don't agree with was
that it shouldn't be privately funded or
we shouldn't have to rely on pride and
you in fact are relying perhaps on this
nft
um
scenario and i would like to hear that
because it is the first time i think
it's been tried at eric you're mocking
me i don't like that what is the smirk
for eric no no it's not it's not look
what we're talking about here has a
history and the history for example in
gravitation there was a prize
offered by
what appeared to be lunatic named babson
and the gravity research foundation for
a fair amount of money back in the day
for a prize critiquing gravity and
nobody in the physics community wanted
to touch it up until bryce dewitt wrote
an essay won the money and suddenly
everybody wanted the money because bryce
dewitt had crossed the threshold
so the question of whether people find
this interesting or not interesting
you only get to ask that once money is
available to actually look at the
project and no reputational damage is
available and i guarantee you brian that
if ridiculous amounts of money and
wonderful conferences and flying people
first class was available and all the
top people at the institute for advanced
study piled in and de-risked it in terms
of reputation
i guarantee you this topic would find a
huge number of scientists who say i
think this is the most interesting
problem in the world who right now would
say yeah little green men hard pass no
thanks so what i am trying to say is we
all know
we
the gravity research prize is a perfect
example
of how human scientists are when it
comes to their reputations because
reputation is survival and to pretend
like that's not going on just to say
well your colleagues don't necessarily
agree with you it's like well
let's find out whether the colleagues
agree if we put a large amount of money
and we de-stigmatize it i will make you
a bet that an enormous number of
colleagues suddenly find this incredibly
fascinating how could we do that avi i
mean eric and i have talked and i don't
expect you to have listened to every
single episode of the podcast in the
past eric and i have talked about
you know this this this true truth that
society owes physicists they owe us a
lot we created a transistor we created a
laser we created trillions of dollars
the internet
and so but how do you monetize that
xposed facto it's not so easy as when
you have the escrow account you know and
you're waiting for your deposit to clear
right so how do we do something you know
ahead of time to fund science like this
especially specula actually let's step
away let me let me just ask you a
question abby stepping away from aliens
anything to do with it let's just say we
want to fund basic research which you
and i do eric does
how do we do that use leveraging
before the fact contract with the with
the government or with some other public
sector funds so that we don't get hosed
again like we did with the transistor
the laser the major the the the internet
and and also telecommunication how do we
do that
well there is a there is a path and it
involves a shortcut so in other words
if you uh
discover something that people have
passion for that people care about
and
that could make could be revolutionary
then it will turn minds of a lot of
people at once and in the context of
what we were discussing before if i go
on an expedition to papua new guinea and
i scoop the ocean floor with a sled and
a magnet and i bring up
a piece of equipment that looks like
iphone 100
okay and what i mean by that is
something that you cannot really reverse
engineer but it does
miracles in your hands when you press
some buttons okay suppose it happens you
know just a futuristic i don't like
science fiction but i'm giving you an
example of something that could happen
because we are going to the ocean
and are going to to scoop the the
fragment so suppose we happen to find it
you know whether it exists or not is
part of reality and um we it's just a
fishing expedition and we don't know
what fish we will find so
this is an example where you do the
experiment and if you find it it changes
everything then
everyone in the world will
talk about it
fund it
the scientific community will jump up
and down and say of course we knew that
we always said that in the 60s someone
wrote a paper about something like that
it's actually not new and this person
was you know just a fisherman that found
it it's not important uh that this
person found it it was discussed in the
60s and of course we all now the reason
i say that is there was a congressman
that made anti-gay statements for many
years and then when he left congress he
confessed that he was gay
and could never see
that's a clear illustration of human
nature where people that really want
uh to discuss the subject they can
ridicule it just by looking around and
seeing that other people are ridiculing
it uh and unfortunately you know in
academia it's very prevalent
so the way to change that is to find
something that will
be obvious and change everything and of
course it's not easy you know we would
mostly most likely find fragments of an
iron meteorite not of a but at any event
you should try and the only way not to
find it is by not searching and that's
my
fundamental point that if you have a
prejudice and you say this is too
speculative i don't want to even deal
with it you will never discover
something that you didn't expect even if
it lies on the ocean floor there is this
gadget there you will never go and
search for it and you will feel your
life it's a self-fulfilling prophecy to
remain ignorant so let me ask you
avi assume that you go to papua new
guinea you get huge funding from all of
these billionaires who are crowding your
point i'm very worried about your
billionaire problem on your porch
i have another one tomorrow tomorrow
fantastic
i will send orkin sounds like you have
an infestation so the question is
assume you find nothing or in fact what
you find is so boring and uninteresting
as to
tell
you that you completely screwed up and
that there was nothing to be found
how do you feel the day after
oh no it's um you know if you think
about life we
spend so much effort in directions that
do not prove fruit for even if you are
trying suppose you want to
marry someone a spouse you have to go
through many blind dates that turn out
quite badly okay and if you look at
scientific scientific record of very
accomplished scientists most of the time
you know they write papers that are
not very consequential and so you're
just trying to find the one case that
will make a huge difference and it's
it's difficult life is difficult if it
was easy then everyone would have it so
the point is without trying without
going on dates you will obviously not
marry anyone okay and you have to give
yourself a chance to be wrong and the
way to do it is just like a kid it's a
learning experience we should behave
like kids scientists should be
open-minded curious rather than
protecting their ego protecting their
image so that they can because it's not
about prizes think about it all these
awards and prizes and uh you know that
that we get are completely meaningless
what matters is the intellectual content
of what we find and i would much rather
find this
iphone 100 than win the nobel prize for
some for the fact that the
expansion of the universe is
accelerating
uh because of the intellectual content
of the meaning that it will have to
humanity
okay and assume for the moment just to
take your data analogy that you go on a
blind date and you're not really
connecting and you find out the person
is into the occult and uh not not the
right person for you do you immediately
demand all your money back or do you say
look if i'm going to go on a few dates i
expect that i'm going to pay for a lot
of dinners that lead nowhere
well yeah that's exactly what happened
with the large hadron collider aside
from the higgs the mission was to find
supersymmetry in the natural parameter
space that everyone recommended we
haven't found supersymmetry did anyone
commit suicide as a result no
we just said okay well maybe it's around
the corner maybe it's at home
or maybe isn't it great that we found
that low energy supersymmetry
isn't present because we could have
written an endless number of articles on
low energy supersymmetry at the
electroweak scale
and without actually having an
accelerate we wouldn't know i mean i was
just at this conference where the person
said here are all the models we've ruled
out here's the one model that remains
and it was amazing to look at parameter
space and right you know at a certain
level um if you keep hearing about some
gal that you should really
go on a date with because she's looking
for the same things you are and you find
out that in fact it's not a workable
situation you've paid for dinner but
you've learned something valuable you
don't have to keep listening hey you
really you really need to find out
what's going on with susan these days
exactly you learn no matter what we gain
knowledge as a result of getting more
evidence the only way not to gain
knowledge is to behave like experts
because they say our past knowledge is
all that we need there is nothing else
if we studied rocks in the past
everything in the sky is rocks
that's it must be natural and then the
last question avi just to to do this
what do you think the most
persuasive scientific critiques that
you're worrying about of your own
projects and your own theories are as
opposed to which ones play well or
seem to be damning like in other words
what is it that gets through to you with
that you're worrying about at night
because i really want people to
understand that trying to get rid of
silliness isn't trying to get rid of
critique it's a question of you really
have to focus on
what is germane what's collegial and
what is constructive so what is it that
you're worried about
with extraterrestrial technology and
probes and visitors that you might have
most wrong here
yeah so i'll give you a specific example
in the case of a muammua the most
unusual anomaly was that
apparently there was
it exhibited an excess
acceleration away from the sun excess
push away from the sun by
such some mysterious force because we
didn't see it evaporating there was no
rocket effect
and what worried me the most is that the
measurement of the trajectory was wrong
was off and so together with my postdoc
john forbes we really looked really
carefully into the data what could be
errors that they didn't account for
and i was
and that was after we wrote the paper
with shmuel bialy where we suggested
maybe it's an artificial object a very
thin object pushed by reflecting
sunlight so what worried me is that the
measurement is wrong and
we went through this with my postdoc for
several months to check that there the
conclusions that were drawn from the
data uh were correct and we confirmed it
but
this is an example where a situation
where you know there seemed to be an
anomaly but it's actually in the way the
data was analyzed and not
you know in in in the properties of the
objects and i constantly worry about
this and i could be wrong you know i was
wrong in in some other cases in my
scientific career and
but that's part of my learning
experience i'm i'm not afraid of being
wrong and i think if you don't dare to
collect more data you will never figure
out what's behind anomalies
my biggest fear is that i'm being
propagandized by a disinformation
campaign that was constructed by the
government
to keep certain things secret and i have
no hard data but i have mountains of
indirect evidence and so
i'm very i'm worried that in fact there
is no there there at a scientific level
but there will be there there at a
government trust and disinformation
level so that's like one of my biggest
concerns
yeah but also actually
i'm talking about objects that were
discovered by astronomers no no no you
were talking about a different issue i
i'm just saying
but i've never said anything one way or
the other about a muammar or anything
like that right but one thing i should
advise you eric is
um
don't don't worry too much about
government here we're dealing with
nature okay so government is completely
secondary they cannot change what nature
gives us okay and i give much more
respect to nature than to government
because nature obeys according to
physics a universal set of laws
government does not
so guys i want to pivot and the
remaining time we all have hopefully uh
to another subject with your permission
and that's um that's an issue that avi
has written very uh poetically and
lovingly about uh and it involves
academic um academia but specifically
scientific family i i want to refer
people to the in the show notes down
there when you when you go down there
and you take out your thumb and you
click the like button uh if you want to
see these guys back on this podcast or
people like that in this conversation
when you're down there you'll see a link
to avi's second medium post and it's
about academia and it's the joys of an
academic family avi
what what prompted you to write this
this lovely touching article and uh i
wanna eric hasn't seen it perhaps but uh
i wanna discuss on what academia could
be what it hasn't been maybe for the
past decades and and where it could be
with things like we've talked about with
nfts with uh daos with uh ai and other
acronyms so avi take it away what was
this article's intention
well uh last week my former students and
postdocs about 60 of them organized the
conference to celebrate my 60th birthday
it was a scientific conference but
during the coffee breaks and at the
banquet
many of them came over to me to tell me
for the first time that i made a big
impact on their lives
and that was a big revelation and
the
the biggest reward that i ever received
uh or you can say call it an award uh in
a sense because
i always try to help
young people people and and when i was
department chair i was always on the
side of the faculty if there was an
issue with the higher administration i
fought for the faculty and the same
deal with students and and postdocs that
were mine i always sided with them and
tried to help them
because i i
very much sympathize with their
vulnerability and
and so during the banquet for example
last week
many of them stood up and and
mentioned stories and you know some of
these brought tears to my eyes i simply
forgot how much i helped some of them
and they brought it up and it was very
moving to me now we also had a soccer
match between the postdocs and the
faculty and i should say the faculty one
and two zero and i i was fortunate to
score one of the goals but uh the good
news is that the postdocs will become
faculty in the coming years um and all
together people told me after this
conference that
it was one of the most unusual
conferences they ever attended because
it did feel like an academic family
where
like-minded people my students and
postdocs that think you know just like
me since i sort of trained them in this
way they are curious about a wide range
of topics and they never spoke to each
other each of them knew me from the
interaction with me and not
they did not interact among themselves
so for them it was really
the first family meeting and you know in
a way if something bad happens to me in
my morning jog if a car runs over me
every every morning when i
i jog at 5 00 a.m so that there isn't
much risk but it's possible that the car
would run over me now i have the sort of
peace of mind that my academic dna will
be preserved in this very uh how should
i say uh vibrant uh
group of of
innovative scholars that are sort of my
academic children and there is a lot of
joy in recognizing that
some bliss i would say and being in
martha's vineyard all of last week in
their company
was probably the best week of my life uh
and it's very different you have to
understand it's very different from
conferences where you know that are
specialized on a specific topic here it
was more the theme of the way i do my
science that was translated into the
careers of so many people that
have a common thread which is let's be
driven by curiosity let's forget about
the nonsense of trying to prove that we
are smart and everyone was conversing in
a very collegial fashion
so
you know that was and i mentioned that
in my uh medium essay that anyone is
interested yeah so linked down below
eric you and i have talked before about
academia and in particular harvard and i
don't think that it's a secret that
harvard kind of has an outsized impact
on the culture of academia it's our
oldest institution i believe um next to
the second best ivy league uh which is
brown university where i got my picture
but uh but avi when we look at it we
think about what these institutions mean
you and i do the same thing
and i'm convinced eric should have done
this but he decided to to go off in a
different direction but as professors we
stand in front of a piece of rock and we
scrape on it with another piece of rock
called chalk and we basically are just
up there this age on the stage in front
of in front of people for the first time
in i think history as far as i know i
taught a cosmology class this quarter
that i used uh demonstrations and
experiments in i did experiments in
thermodynamics i did experiments in
acoustic waves teach cmb acoustic
oscillations i did spectroscopy i did
all sorts of fun stuff geiger counter
heavy water
but even that you know i can't really
hurt my arm patting myself on the back
so it wasn't that way
what can we do about academia eric
especially i want to get from your
opinion you have you have reached
millions of people with very vivid
displays and i put a link to the portal
and your web page down below
how can we reform education how can we
cancel not cancel harvard but how can we
reform this this institution is a
thousand years old since the first
university in bologna italy we've
basically not changed at all and and i i
think it's it's overdue for a change
eric first you then avi
um
more or less i think we had things
pretty well in hand until we lost
our discipline hope and funding
so my my feeling about this is that
in order to restore this we're going to
have to have some huge wins
that come from people who cannot be
subsumed in this sort of sweeping
critique that has crashed over academics
that somehow
academics is the most bigoted uh
exclusive um
[Music]
you know toxically male
environment
lots of these things have have some
truth to them but there was also a lot
of things that
um
that happened that were miraculous
wonderful cultures like isidore robbie's
lab at columbia that allowed people who
were barred from universities at that
level to come and do scientific work
where more or less
there has to be a scientific underground
an underground railroad to smuggle good
ideas good people
the money they need the support they
need you know i i heard about avi's
conference celebrating his 60th birthday
happy birthday professor loeb um but
the thing that really made me sad was
that as an orphan as a guy who did not
have an advisor um
[Music]
i can tell you that there's a different
romance towards being on your own and
there's a romance towards being part of
a world view
and i think that the people like avi who
try to make sure that their students
survive who are no nonsense when it
comes to the research
who make sure that they have a legacy
are really important and i think harvard
in particular is the pivot point harvard
is both the best and worst place in the
entire academic universe
it gets incredible people it gets
it's incredibly tolerant of all sorts of
crazy ideas and it's incredibly brutal
backstabbing behind the scenes back of
house nonsense at the same time
and so in a certain sense what we have
to do is to recognize that the most
important part of academics is to
restore some concept of professional
ethics
so that people have the freedom to share
their ideas that they know that they're
going to have an ability to feed their
family the next day
that they have to uphold professional
ethics or they're out because we cannot
afford an even small number of
relatively smart people
to destroy the entire thing by infecting
it with with snark and twitter culture
as as we've seen with journalism
so i think that roughly speaking we need
to have some huge wins the huge
winds need to come from individuals not
groups
those individuals need to be communally
minded they need to say very clearly
that we need more resources we need to
shut down weaker phd programs we need to
focus on research and not teaching
because
it's very in vogue to think that a
university is primarily focused on
teaching a research university is
focused primarily on research and allows
for teaching to happen
and there's a reason if you want to go
to a college you need to go to a college
but part of the problem is that a lot of
things that made our great research
universities fantastic institutions
don't play well to 20 22 years
and those of us who believe in the
mission of a university and its own
diversity equity and inclusion
program called merit
need to stand up vocally
and say certain people need to leave
certain programs need to be shut down
more money needs to be found we need to
stop lying that everything has to do
with groups and not individuals power
laws are everywhere
and we've got to be more courageous
standing up for ourselves and not wilt
every time somebody calls you a white
supremacist for just saying the obvious
truth
um if i may
bring up
several other aspects that need
improvement there is a lot of room for
improvement i must say
coming from within academia um harvard's
president bakao
announced that he will step down
a year from now and i was asked by the
crimson
what do i think is a good future for
harvard then
i thought i said that it has been 70
years
since
james conant was the last scientist who
served as harvard's president and that
shows
and nowadays society is very much driven
by science and technology and my point
is it doesn't mean that we should
abandon the humanities in fact there is
a huge role for the humanities to be
playing in the modern technological age
for example lots of ethical questions
that ai systems social media bring
to the front and philosophers and
ethicists
have a very important role in shaping
the future of society but it needs to be
about the future not about the past i
mean of course we can study what ancient
greeks said but they never had the
gadgets that we have so we need to bring
up new philosophical ideas to bear with
the new reality that we live through and
so that's the future that the university
should aspire to
promote and
and therefore it
the next president needs to be a
scientist now i
don't think they would listen to my
advice they haven't listened last time
around
but that is my sincere hope that you
know science and technologies
will lead the way and the basic message
of science is sharing of knowledge and
cooperation and science does not adhere
to national borders and we are all part
of the human species and the knowledge
that we acquire through science should
be shared and these are very noble ideas
in this age of isolation and separation
and fighting each other and wars and so
forth you know the message the science
brings like let's work together and make
a better future for ourselves just to
give give you another example um ezra
klein
on his new york times podcast a few days
ago wa spent 15 minutes trying to answer
a question the following question uh
should i decide not to have children uh
because of the implications to climate
change that was the question and to me
the answer
you know it would have taken me a few
seconds to answer that question that he
spent 15 minutes and here is my answer
you know
the future is
within the realm of
our scientific accomplishments we can
this
make policy based on our scientific
understanding we can
decide how to live our planet and go to
space
uh and not risk
the future of humanity by a single point
catastrophe here on earth based on
science and technology and so my point
is we should have as many kids as we
want as the more the better and then
let them shape a better future using
science you know and this could be our
biological kids or they could be our
technological kids you know using uh
ai systems to help us because they will
become smarter than us in the future so
i'm much more in favor of the
replacement replacing darwin's principle
of
survival of the fittest with survival of
the optimist you know you have to be an
optimist so that the future will be much
more promising if you decide not to have
kids is as if you decided uh you prefer
death over life right you know
and and you know albert camus
in his essay uh
the myth of sisypus the first sentence
there says the biggest question in
philosophy
is whether life is worth living
or we commit suicide you know and that's
the biggest question in philosophy i say
if you expand expand that to humanity as
a whole to our civilization
the biggest question is whether humanity
is worth
longevity you know surviving longer
forever and this is the most important
question in the context of science not
in the context of philosophy but not on
the brain actually i think it's even
deeper than that and and just to point
out you know there's a saying the
optimist builds the plane but the
pessimist builds the parachute uh it's
appropriate to talk about this on the
eve of the eve of father's day of course
and it doesn't take as you said it
doesn't take children we don't all have
to be fathers or mothers or parental
units of unspecified gender uh we could
also be ideological and and and uh
thought leaders thought mentors men and
women to children but i want to ask you
something obvi that eric and i have
spoken a lot about is the lack of
diversification of the portfolio of
those that speak about like elon musk
who we we both have affection for and
admiration for in a lot of ways but but
see criticism as well uh but eric you
know uh one of the listeners asking a
question on my uh where i take questions
on my community page my youtube channel
is you know why why are we so kind of
all in one basket putting our eggs in
all in one basket how do you react to
elon musk's approach to you know let's
become interplanetary let's go to one
other planet
let's double our planets and our
portfolio management what do you think
about elon musk i've never asked you avi
what's your uh uh you know uh analysis
of history
i wanted to say that
another thing missing in academia that i
didn't have a chance to mention is
diversity of ideas
okay and we touched about it before but
basically the idea of tenure is all
about allowing people to have job
security so that they can promote ideas
that are not along the beaten path okay
and unfortunately it's not being used
when people get tenure they become lazy
and they don't do much they become dead
wood very often so it's being abused
this privilege is really an
amazing privilege i mean we don't get
paid a lot in academia but we do have
the privilege of job security and we
should take advantage of it we should
explore ideas that are not conventional
and that's another thing that needs to
change in academia now coming back to
elon musk of course you know there are
major hurdles for example if you go to
the surface of mars you will be
bombarded by cosmic rays and your body
would not survive for more than a year
or a few years uh you that needs to be
solved and one way is to go down
underground you know in a cave and they
live there or there needs to be special
uh infrastructure built to protect the
people over there and also people on on
travel there uh you don't want i mean
you don't want to send people to the
death and and so that those practical
concerns were not attended to in a very
public way in a very science oriented so
i i really think we should solve the
health
uh risks that the people will face when
going long term to mars otherwise i
think
by the way um i don't think humans are
really the future of humanity okay i
think the future of humanity is some
very advanced form of autonomous robots
with artificial intelligence i do
believe that
and i'm proud of our technological kids
because
you know they will be able to survive
much better you know why would some
random processes of
on the surface of earth in a soup of
chemicals
make the best possible uh outcome you
know that to me it sounds like well we
got uh to this point but we have a lot
of faults you know if you look at human
history uh clearly humans have a lot of
faults and
perhaps we can build a system that will
be better than humans and i'm looking
forward for the first ai uh scientists
you know because they will not be driven
by their ego if they see an object that
looks like
a rocket booster
they will not call it a rock i want to
ask you about that avi i'm sorry to
interrupt eric i'm going to give you a
chance i'm going to give you a requisite
30 seconds to respond but uh
but avi i i i want to push back with
love and kavod and respect okay so this
guy here do you know what his what what
he said his happiest thought was ava you
know i'm sure you know what he said as
happy as thought was right
that he in free fall you experience no
gravitational field now let's let's
unpack an ai einstein a e a i e e a e um
how does such a thing know about free
fall like what does that even mean and
second of all what does happiness mean
to such in other words are you really
serious do you think ai physicists are
around the corner or is that kind of
wishful thinking oh no no i
i give
no you can imagine a system that will uh
basically digest data provided to it by
instruments directly so the instruments
will send the data to the ai system that
will
analyze it and try to figure out what's
going on and it's the job of a scientist
right now it looks like you know a
miracle but in principle you know it
could be done by a machine i don't think
humans are necessarily designed for that
purpose you know we were gatherers and
hunters we were not scientists to start
with so our brain is not necessarily
optimized for the purpose of being a
scientist and i have no problem getting
pride uh from a system that outperforms
us i don't have a you know that doesn't
but
uh you know give a blow to to my ego in
any way i in fact i would be extremely
happy if i knew that
we can build a system that corrects the
faults of humans
okay so eric um stepping back from the
ai stuff to the to uh any any of the
topics that i rudely interrupted you
over no no no no
by the way three jews on a podcast i'm
surprised that i'm the only one
interrupting either one of the two of
you so you guys are clearly much better
bred and uh influenced by our just
imagine that the number of opinions that
we have right now and it is getting
close to shabbat i don't want to
interfere with avi's uh shabbat but uh i
do want to thank you guys uh wait wait i
didn't say anything no i know but go on
okay go on but by the way you know if
three jews are on an island you know how
many synagogues you need for that
for them four you need four yeah because
you need one that their foot would never
step in
[Music]
eric um okay so
where were we
the ai
physicists um
look i'm partial to humans and i'm
actually partial to egos i mean all
sorts of things that i like everybody
has decided are terrible um i like
humans i like egos
i'm glad i agree with both of you that
we should have children um and that ezra
should probably
remove himself and leave the rest of us
alone in the gene pool um
look we're in dire circumstances and
this
what we're looking for is an analog of
the neutron
and the neutron changed everything
because it allowed chain reactions and
that ushered in the atomic age or the
semiconductor changed everything
or the world wide web that came out of
cern these are things that changed
everything whether it's
you know radio frequency communications
we're looking for something that
obviates the needs for rockets rockets
are sort of embarrassing in 2022 because
there's not that much that can be
reached
so you know it's like buying a huge boat
um
for a small lake there's just not that
many places you can go um
so my feeling about this is we have to
reacquaint ourselves with the possible
we've been living so long under einstein
and boar
that we've forgotten
that
their limitations may not be our
limitations if we can crack a puzzle and
the neutron was 1932
so it's within living memory
what we need to do is to reacquaint
ourselves with the idea that finding a
single new field or new way of looking
at space-time
or
some adjustment to this order that has
settled in is now almost 50 years old
is necessary for us to dream again
and we nobody dreams about finding you
know gilligan's island was about an
uncharted desert isle it would be very
weird to think about an uncharted desert
isle in 2022
um
because we've mapped the earth but we
haven't mapped the heavens so i think
it's really important to recognize that
i fully support my friend avi on his
quest for the ai
intelligences and the post-human
discoverers but i'm actually really
optimistic that the next theories might
have new possibilities for us humans
laden with ego though we may be
for us to survive each other and i i
really believe that
at some point elon is going to get past
his
fascination with spacex rockets and
using mars as the sales job
and recognize that he stumbled onto a
very correct paradigm which is that we
are in dire straits if we don't get
diversification those humans are never
going to build avi's next level ai
scientists
and i would really like to see ego come
back in people to be hyper motivated to
put in 100 hour weeks
chasing dreams and to try to acquaint us
with the cosmos
that we may be able to visit and people
part of the problem is the instant you
talk like this the conversation has been
pre-hijacked people immediately think
you mean mars because elon has said that
we're going to survive because we're
going to decamp to mars which is not
really a realistic proposition via
rockets
and then the next part of it is oh you
must be talking about faster than light
travel
alcubiary warp drives or
wormholes because those are the only
things that einstein would allow you to
use to dream about the cosmos the idea
of saying post-einstein that i accept
einstein for who he is and what he did
but he is not the last word and there
would probably not be a schwarzschild
singularity nor a friedman robertson
walker singularity
if his theory was complete it's probably
merely effective
and that is the challenge of our times
to get out of the straight jacket
so the thing that really attracts me to
avi's program in part
is
if there's a one in ten thousand chance
that we might find a technology that
makes use of science that we don't know
yet
um
that's really worth doing because it's
not a paradigm that has ever occurred to
us to get a technology
beyond human the only analog of this is
biology where you have a blind
watchmaker and the theory of selection
means that there are pathways and
pathways
beyond pathways in a cell that do things
that we don't understand so that the
principle of natural selection has done
a marvelous job engineering technologies
we can only dream about
but the idea that something might have
engineered probes and vehicles to visit
us
is an enticement to thinking about a
cosmos that can be visited and certainly
not by rockets for those of us with
humans families and egos who i'm huge
fans of and remain so to this day
yeah and i i completely agree with eric
that albert einstein was not the
smartest scientist that ever lived since
the big bang 13.8 billion years ago
there must have been a smarter scientist
on an exoplanet
a billion years ago and the civilization
that benefited from the wisdom of that
scientist must have launched probes that
would have reached us by now
yeah
well guys i am grateful for you
giant enormous intellect for a weinstein
if not an einstein and for a lobe uh
that is a cranial lobe uh and a loeb
that i love uh speaking to
guys i got into this podcasting because
you know my day-to-day job i'm building
experiments i'm i'm looking not for
interstellar meteorites but i'm trying
to remove the imprint of cosmic dust
from my cmb experiments uh before we
depart for this particular occasion i
want to ask each of you if you have
anything that you want to mention
advertise besides uh your bitcoin rig
eric or but
avi where can people find you what are
you most interested in is there anything
else that we should discuss on this
particular episode
well i have a listing of my opinion
essays that you can find on my website
at harvard university
and the every few days i write a new one
and you can follow up
on the latest developments and
with me whatever what that what you see
is what you get so just trust me and if
we find something exciting uh you
wouldn't know about it
eric how about you everyone's uh
everyone's curious what you're up to
well i mean i've been
to some extent very much focused on
on physics recently
talking to colleagues and going to
meetings and things
what i'm
most alarmed by is that we get in touch
with the desperation of the current
moment with putin in ukraine recognize
that
we're no longer kidding around and that
it's not safe to continue in this
idiom even if we probably survive this
particular misadventure
it's really important that we
drive more people towards science and
make sure that when they get there
they've got great lives ahead of them as
opposed to this
madness of having them eke out a living
and constantly apologizing for
everything interesting so that they can
stay in the good graces i i would look
um
at a two 2014 article that i wrote
called uh
m theory string theory is the only game
in town
to the question of what scientific idea
is ready for retirement
and there's also an article about
einstein's revenge
which had to do with the idea that
people who wanted to quantize gravity
ended up instead geometrizing the
quantum
and after listening to what is now
currently considered cutting edge
physics theory i want to just point out
that a lot of people are leaving for
quantum computation trying to do quantum
computers trying to do machine learning
we've got to keep the excitement going
uh a generation or two has failed at
theoretical physics and it's time for
voices that we haven't heard and new
people entering the field to be given
free reign
in particularly not constantly dogged by
the quantum field theory crowd i've come
to the conclusion that quantum field
theory is
maybe our most powerful theory but we
don't understand it well enough
to allow it to
select for good new ideas and i think
what we have to do is we have to
recognize that we are in a desperate
search for new ideas beyond einstein
they will ultimately have to conform to
experiment and make sense of quantum
field theory which works very well but
we're going to have to look to make
physics in particular exciting and we
can't back off it not everything is
equally exciting fundamental physics is
the only thing that i know of that is a
reasonable hope of getting us out of the
problem that fundamental physics
originally got us into so i think that
this alien stuff is really important
even if i think it's relatively unlikely
that it's going to do what i hope it
could do for us we're going to have to
find every possible way of breaking out
of einstein's prison so organizing an
einsteinian prison break i think should
be all of our top priorities at the
moment because we're in pretty dire
straits but we're definitely a group
worth saving so that's where i am that's
where i'm at let's put them in jail
behind bars made of omumua skin
um guys uh this has been a treat we've
had over 2 000 people
uh in the room at one time and um
but really what you guys uh mean in your
openness in your articulation of some of
the most complex topics that can exist
and some of the most perilous
politically and otherwise i think it's
really important avi i just want to say
one thing you said maybe the next
president should be a scientist and i
was thinking halawa it should be for the
president of the united states as well
wouldn't that be
nice or it could be a disaster who knows
i mean those movies that you've seen you
know with the pr anyway um so uh for me
i want to express my gratitude i'm brian
keating host of the into the impossible
podcast as well as dr brian keating on
youtube where i do videos from an
experimental perspective because these
brainiacs like eric like avi and like
many of the colleagues i've had on um
are theoreticians and i think they're
incredibly brilliant but i think the
experimentalists need to get a little
bit of attention every now and then so
yeah that's my unique angle
boys it's been fun avi yomole
shabbat shalom and eric it's so good to
see you as it always is and i hope you
guys will come back maybe at the end of
the summer we'll get some clarity uh
what's going on with these with these
government panels and so forth and we'll
be able to discuss the real scientific
issues